今天课堂分享的议题是其他活动专案的创作
经验分享
一个是敦煌的活动
一个是汉服汉服的活动
因为我在浙江的西塘有筹备了一个汉服文化周
再来就是世博会
10年前上海的世博会很特别吧
一个是世博会
一个是敦煌一带一路的活动
一个是汉服相关的主题歌
当然咯在分享这些活动专案之前
我们先来朗诵一首韵脚诗
这首韵脚诗叫青春
断线的风筝
其实还有一种可能强化纤维的鱼线
勾住的那天黄昏
窗外电线杆上的麻雀意味着抵御寒冷
于是乎我们最在意的青春街角的演唱会门票
就成长而言
已经算完成期末考的分数为一双失望的眼神
联考前球鞋终于放弃了对篮筐的瞄准
于是乎我们最在意的青春
吞下秋叶后
白杨木的年轮又胖了一层
蜻蜓的路线还是只适合出没在乡村
离家出走的猫
开始觉得当初很愚蠢
于是乎我们最在意的青春诗就是这样子
轻轻柔柔
不一样的一个感受
接下来分享的是敦煌的一场专案活动
敦煌国际文化博览会
绝色敦煌之夜很长吧
因为那个活动很大
我们就是负责敦煌角色之夜
基本上他是一带一路的活动
我负责的领域是音乐的执行跟主题曲的撰写
音乐的执行是我是整个角色职业的音乐总监
我们找了各个领域音乐的相关人才
有编曲老师
有配乐的老师
有作曲填词
当然是由我负责
还有歌手
这场敦煌角色之夜
我总共写了三首歌
你就知道那个活动有多盛大
但是我们今天只会分享其中一首
其他的两首是飞天
由韩红所演唱
这是敦煌谣
由雷佳所演唱
我们今天分享的是九色鹿
是霍尊所演唱的
他的表演的段落非常的长
所有的走秀配乐我都是盯场
很辛苦
但是很有成就感
通常作词者的身份比较被动
除非你是制作人
制作某种程度也像电影的导演
他找了各路的人马
他找了灯光师
摄影师
场记剧务美术
化妆师
甚至编剧
他把这些专业的人才齐聚一堂
去完成一个影像的作品
但以音乐的领域来讲
制作人就是等于导演
他找了作词作曲编曲配乐歌手
甚至录音师来完成一个音乐相关的专案
大部分的状况下
我是被动的
只担任作词者的身份
但是因为这个活动很有趣
而且对方说服了我
我觉得好吧
没有去过敦煌
起码去一趟敦煌
我觉得非常非常的值得
而且我还骑到了骆驼
就是敦煌的月牙泉
那个月牙泉几乎终年不枯竭
然后它的形状像月亮上弦
月的弯曲就很特别
沙漠地带
明明旁边都是沙漠
那这个泉水却永远不会枯竭
历史上它会有移位
他可能是地下伏流的关系
整个池塘会移位
但是它不会消失
就觉得哇我们跟历史连结在一起了
参与了某一段历史
因为敦煌光这两个字就很有历史的重量
所以呢我就带着忐忑的心情
跟雀跃的感觉去参与了这场盛会
在执行上
当然编曲配乐是别的朋友在执行的
除了我去监督之外
我比较负责的是歌词的段落
歌词的段落
那时候想一体要围绕整个敦煌去出发
所以记得专案活动一定要切记
一定要贴近活动方的一个主轴
那这个活动方的主轴呢就是敦煌壁画
我们看了好多书
而且他还开放了对外不开放的洞窟给我们看
我就觉得这趟旅行很值得
敦煌研究院的人员带我去参观
那些一般游客不会进入的地方
就觉得天呐
几千年前的壁画居然还维持着
而且有些壁画的彩绘的那些色调还栩栩如生
就觉得我第一次跟历史如此亲近
然后呢我们去参观壁画的过程中
就开始找素材
找到了飞天
因为敦煌壁画的那些神佛
他有飞天的形象
好这个主题定调了
再想说敦煌敦煌应该有一首属于自己的歌
我想来想去好吧
那就定为敦煌谣
那是另外一首歌
然后这首歌是九色鹿
九色鹿是敦煌壁画里面的传说
就是鹿王本纪里面的一个传说
他有一段佛教的故事很吸引人
各位同学如果有兴趣就百度上打敦煌九色鹿
整个故事就跑出来了
故事内容呢我就在这里不加以的阐述了
直接进入活动上的一个创作需求
当初定好主题之后呢
就开始去经营文字的结构
因为我同时写了三首歌
东皇瑶飞天九色鹿
我还要避免他的词汇不一样
可是明明同一个地方啊
那个真的是好进好之
我要做出一个区隔开来
但最后还是做到了
因为时间上是有的
不是一到就开始创作
去之前已经在收集资料了
所以去之前的准备工作就很重要
就是你在接触一个活动方案的时候
不可能到了定点的时候才开始去收集资料
跟对方开会
对方给一些企划的方向跟内容就是来不及的
因为你一定在出发前就已经知道所有的信息
所以你应该出发前就做相关的功课
好的
接下来我们就进入歌词的内容
一开始创作的时候
基本上不假思索
九色鹿这个词汇一定要在副歌的
第一行
这是没得讨论的空间
所以呢我的副歌的第一行
就是壁画里的九色鹿啊
不再孤独
然后第二遍壁画里的九色鹿啊
他跳着舞嗯
很明显的记忆点
九色鹿
再来副歌
第一大段的副歌的第二行
我的故事里尽是宽恕
因为九色鹿是佛教里面的一个故事
还有个典故出处
这千年的莫高窟
等谁来描述
放下爱恨嗔痴
虔诚而清楚好
第二遍的副歌要改了
第一行可以留着第二遍的副歌
我改成我在微笑中放慢脚步
思路不再刮起风沙般的雾
佛法一读再读
霉不在景处
画面感风沙思路壁画
这是必备的一个格子环境
这首歌曲创作的没有很辛苦
因为非常的聚焦
出发前做功课
然后去参观莫高窟
整个环节是很顺畅的
虽然一次写了三首歌
但是创作就很奇怪
有时候你单独写一首的一段
你可能拖两个礼拜讲不出自己满意的作品
但是只要你有想法
你有热情或者是资料搜罗的够齐备
天哪一个专案里面
居然写了三种不同题材的主题曲
还是办得到的
这个就是创作迷人
也是纠葛的地方
就是一下子有很能量
强大的创作一下子枯竭
遇到瓶颈了
写不出来
但是创作好玩的地方就在这里
不可控不可控的人生才有趣
所有的事情心想事成
那还得了
没有挑战的吗
没有挑战就不会有阻碍
不会有阻碍
就不会有挫折
没有挫折
基本上你就不会有记忆
那接下来分享前段一路的驼铃风沙
在听一夜的羌笛
乡愁难平
这是a one a two哦
一样一口枯井
月色冷清
一树的古琴愁肠道尽
前段呢我一样用的刀马旦的语法
就是一当第一个字非常的好用
但你不能太常用
就就是说我之所以写的很快
是因为知道怎么写的都是一
但是词汇跟DMD完全不一样
这个就是创作的技巧
有些关键字或特殊的语义结构
你可以重复使用
但是呢你后面的内容要完全的不一样好
接下来我再讲其他的段落
a one的第三行要几番轮回
路过多少风景
才能在天涯转弯处遇见曾经
然后第二大段要几世伤心
历经多少宿命
才舍得将缘分归隐缓缓清醒
因为佛教讲轮回
所以你还是要深入一体
轮回的话就是所谓的宿命
宿命就可以接清醒
你想到什么呢
很多成员没有了断
那这首歌之所以写的节奏比较快
是因为我已经掌握了书写的方向跟概念
这个很重要
只要你有概念跟方向这几个关键的词汇出来
有时候一个下午就可以
整首歌AMA2B二B二全部写出来
这个状况就是出现在Z4的专案
所以呢虽然焦头烂额
写了三个主题
但是三个主题都有很明确的创作方向
基本上都没有经过太多的煎熬
就把它创作出来
接下来要分享一首我们蔡同学蔡依林的作品
2010年上海世博会台湾馆主题曲
叫台湾心跳声
原来介绍一个地方的风土民情
其实反而比较好写
因为很多画面感的关键字
基本上就占了歌词篇幅的60%
剩下的40%就是创意了
就是语义上的一个创意
令人耳目一新的创意
这个活动很有趣
我当初还去台湾馆世博
然后他们在放台湾心跳声
还有做那个天灯的小饰品
就是一个文创的一个东西
就觉得哇好特别哦
居然创作完之后还去到了这个台湾馆
那台馆的这个感觉还是做成天灯
平息天灯的样子就很具象
就是文化的连接性很强
因为所有的城市和地区去那边设主题馆
一定会把他们的文化带过来
一定会用他们的视野去诠释
主题馆里面的文化内涵
所以那趟的参访之旅收获非常的丰满
台湾心跳声这个段落它并不是副歌的记忆点
这是我强调过的很弹性的运用
创作上少一点伤痕
多一点
掌声
少一点
战争多一点
单纯认真
用棒球魂挥汗去体会青春
用心听着那台湾的心跳声
台湾心跳声是出现在副歌最后一段
他还是关键字
但是它不是记忆点
接下来我们分享的是a one跟a two
a one跟A2呢
我同时放了两个关键词汇
一个是永和豆浆
一个是龙山寺
这两个词汇呢非常具有台湾的文化符号
所以一个段落放一句就够了
那常春藤攀上生锈的消防栓
像蝴蝶离不开有花香的地方
宁静的小巷
一杯永和豆浆
我在细细品尝恬淡的家乡
永和豆浆
第二段霓虹灯点亮
关于夜视的想象
但夜市也是算谈独有的一个饮食文化
但是其他的城市也是有意识
所以他文化符号的专属性没有那么的强
好孩子们捉迷藏在找爱吃的糖
昏黄的夕阳
龙山市的老乡
我虔诚点着香
手拿一注
希望就是这样子
两个关键字就够了
接下来我们再分享的是另外一段副歌
少一点仇恨多一点
我们少一点寒冷
多一点温存
用狂草写云门
用风炮逐一座城
妈祖永恒世世代代的前程
天灯冉冉上升
K许下愿望
就别等天灯出现咯
云门舞集也出现了
就是非常具有台湾的调性
所以呢你去创作这样的一个主题专栏歌
其实对我而言比较好写
最后分享一下他的rap
他的rap台湾的视觉词汇就更多
我一路的导读
因为日本比较长
江南平原等待收割是一整片幸福的颜色
屏东黑尾鱼直接等于快乐
一路蜿蜒的淡水河
那陡峭的是太鲁阁
一派乐天的性格美浓纸伞怎么折
三叶木雕怎么磕
这块土地有很多很多的选择
仔细看八家将的装独特
我说亲爱亲爱的
我们故事说到这
就这样
充满了台湾的文化符号和词汇
所以是一个很完整的台湾心跳声
接下来要分享的一个活动方案
跟汉服有关
汉服是我很热爱的一个传统领域
汉服文化周就是一个文化的嘉年华
会很过瘾
这样子这个文化的嘉年华会
当然需要一个重量级的主题曲
那这首主题曲是周同学的曲
然后我的词好
接下来我们就分享一下汉服这个概念
汉服是汉民族的传统衣服
不是汉代的衣服
之前媒体在访问
他说诶那你们推广汉服
那宋服唐服呢
我说哦不对不对
汉服是汉民族的传统衣服
而不是指汉朝的衣服
那什么是汉服的服装格式呢
就是交领右衽系带宽袍
所有的交领是他的领子是交叉的
所以右边是往右去折叠
就这样子这样折过来
有时候你看古装剧
大概是明代以前的古装剧
就很明显交领有人是汉服的一个服饰特色
我们在浙江西塘得到了当地领导的大力的辅助
我们把汉服文化周变成西塘的一个文化名片
每一年汉服文化节的时候
成千上万的人去参与
非常的惊人
它基本上是海内外汉服圈最大的文化盛世了
我们每一年大概在10月底
11月初
为期四天三夜
活动内容非常的多元
其中有亮点就是朝代的方正秀
所有的方阵就是一个队伍成方块形的向前移动
那每一个朝代都有代表的服饰
可能春秋战国
汉代
唐代宋明
一个朝代一个朝代的走
就是很吸引媒体的报道
因为这样子的一个文化盛会这么盛大
而且历史这么悠久
非常的少见
那这首歌叫做汉服青史
一听就很有历史感
我跟大家分享一下它的歌词结构
首先我们分享的是副歌
我魂依旧
汉服青史
留千年后系带宽袍成传
说
就是穿戴的一个形式
我魂依旧
汉服千古愁
卓交领右衽在等候
一个是千古流
一个是千古愁
这个是副歌
副歌基本上第一遍唱的时候
我只写一段的歌词
最后重复唱的时候
我才换了另外一个意境
那我把那个意境跟大家分享一下
第二遍
最后的副歌是我魂依旧
汉服青史留待何时回
归正朔无所求
武魂依旧
汉服千古愁如醇酒
千年的寂寞
就是个感叹
这样子的浮世美应该回来现代
这样的浮世美应该为现代人所熟知
所认识
并且推广好
接下来我们大概分享一下主歌
渡船口
一叶扁舟
天悠悠水东流
叹世道何时月明江辽阔人独酌
醉饮乡愁多少年
你是否也有梦回长安的时候
他的调性历史会很浓稠
因为在推广一个传统的服饰之美
叫汉服
这样子的一个歌曲呢
基本上就是focus在一个节气里面
所以呢这样子的一个歌服务的对象很明确
你传唱的时候
背景的搭配也都是汉服相关活动的一个简介
这整首歌都是带有古风歌曲的韵味
各位同学如果有兴趣的
可以去参与汉服文化周
对这首歌有兴趣呢
也可以打关键字
你就直接打汉服青史
它就会完整的画面跟音乐出来
活动中的歌对我而言反而好写
他有点像命题式作文
因为命题式作文主轴很明确
他就丢个议题给你
你就把一体扩充变成歌词的内容去呼应它
最难写的反而是他不给提醒
也不是命题作文
也没有任何关键字
也没有任何要求的情歌
他就是完全相信你
让你自由发挥
这种创作的形式有好有坏
这样子的创作的结构呢
有时候会突然出现一个非常出彩的杰作
连你自己都会觉得哇
这是知名度的代表作
通常有时候我创作的时候呢
应该要基于尊重自己的职业背景
所以呢不管多么难写
或者说比较没有共鸣的专案
我一样会教
出一个水平的作品
因为我把它当作工作
但是有感觉的我把它当创作
记得工作和创作不一样
创作是哇这个议题好有感觉哇
这个合作啊
你很喜欢你花更多的精力
更多的时间去写
而且写出来基本上就是你那阵子的代表作
但是工作呢就是交出对方满意的作品
一定要这么做
因为你有一个职业水平的自我尊重
所以不管什么样的案子
一定是拿得出手才可以
差别在说
有些拿得出手的是工作
就是有一定的职业水平
有些是创作
就是你年度的一个代表
也因此呢各位同学创作的世界是不是很大
各种各样的议题跟想象都可以去参与
那今天分享的是活动方案的一个创作经验分享